All right, go for it.
First up at third base,
Magic-User Frankenstein.
M-Matsumura?
Pretty neat, huh? I made him using
the meat left over from that Door.
Play ball!
Why is Matsumura here?
Hey, you all right, junior?
He...
That crazy Kasukabe made him
using parts from a Sorcerer's corpse.
But it's not against the rules,
and it is a Sorcerer. Let them have it.
Hurry up and pitch.
How dare you Hole-dwellers
mess with my best friend's body!
Wait, that's it!
If I take that body home,
Kikurage can revive Matsumura!
Hurry it up!
Dang, I'm so smart.
All right, score!
Matsumura!
Hurry, pull him out!
Be careful, jeez.
You're a great guy.
Second up, at second base: Kasukabe.
All righty.
So Mr. Caiman,
what's the deal with you and Nikaido?
The deal? We're friends.
That means I can have her, right?
Hm. That's none of my business.
Safe!
Nice bunt!
That guy sure is quick on his feet.
Third up, shortstop, Thirteen.
A hit to the right!
What a useless pitcher. Time for Plan A.
Plan A?
Fourth up, catcher. Caiman.
We meet again, lizard guy.
I was going to destroy him, but I'd better
focus on taking Matsumura back instead.
Thirteen, that little prick.
At least...
I don't know why...
...I'll strike you out!
...but he annoys the crap out of me!
All right, three runs!
Shocking!
Look at their long faces.
Atta boy!
I'm such a loser.
Fujita.
What, you came to make fun of me?
Just use your Magic.
-Fifth, at first base: Vaux.
-Let's keep it coming.
Strike! You're out!
What the heck was that?
It was at least 160 km per hour.
My Magic spurts smoke like a bullet.
It's weak and limited,
so it's hardly ever useful.
But I can throw really fast balls
using my smoke.